Tên dịp thắt tùng phó thu tường chính phủ hỗc xuống, thăm làm việc giải quyết bà từ ngày 1,5.
Thực tướng phụ sĩ tấn, phó tổng thăm mua trường của đội nhân dân Việt Nam,
tại đến chào sả dào thượng tướng Anvaro Lục Bết miera,
bui viên bộ chính trị bộ trường bộ các lực lượng buu trang tách mạng của Và.
Tại buổi tiếp thượng Anvaro Lục Bết miera,
tà mơn Việt Nam đã gồm đồng hành hỗ trợ của Và,
mong muốn có đội hai nước tiếp tục ruy trì và đề mạnh hợp tác trên các lĩnh vực,
mà hai bên có khả năng và nhu cầu,
qua đó có phần cùng của quân hệ hai nước hai còn đội.
Thực ra n tới, dự báo tình hình thế giới khu vực tiếp tục có những tất lộn đến
quốc phòng Anning của mỗi nước.
Hai bên cho rằng, quân đội hai nước tần tiếp tục cùng của Và phát tuy tình gồn kết,
bộ vộ vỡ trở lần nhau, vỡ hợp trật trẻ để chiến khai hiệu quả
kể hội thật tác quốc phòng Banh Nam, sẽ đoạn anning khuốc cho mai sấu anning khuốc cho mai tảm,
đã kì kế bởi thằng chiến năm anning khuốc cho mai 1 năm.
Cũng như các nỗi dung hợp tác được lãnh đạo cấp cao hai nước,
hai 1 quốc phòng thống nhất, vô hợp bởi nhu cầu khả năng của Mũ Bên.
Nhân dịm ngày thự tưởng phục sị tấn,
trong mừng quốc bà kìa nghiệm sống nhất xin năm, ngày thằng lập ca lực lượng vũ trang cách mạc.